I'm very glad that we're talking about
renewing globalization and not not
killing globalization which is the
debate that we sometimes hear my name is
Terry Miller I'm director of the center
for international trade in economics at
the heritage foundation before i arrived
at heritage i worked for 32 years as a
US diplomat and had the honor to
represent our country of the United
States as our ambassador to the United
Nations Economic and Social Council and
also as a deputy assistant secretary of
state for economic and global issues so
that gives you a little idea of where
I'm coming from in this discussion we
have a very distinguished panel here
many of whom wrote important essays in
this book that you all have available
and I recommend this book to you
strongly the essays a lot of thought was
put into these they're very concise
they're very wide-ranging and I think
it's well worth anyone's time to read
through this book in its entirety you'll
come out with a much better grasp of the
overall concept of international
economic growth and international
economic relations both the constraints
and the possibilities that lie inside of
that now we're here to discuss the g20
meeting and the g20 has an agenda but I
think it's important that we recognize
that each leader each of these 20
leaders that come to this meeting have
their own social and political context
their own economic context they they
come from countries that are in
different economic situations they come
they come with different political
strength sometimes different political
systems they have different pressures on
them some have a lot more pressure than
others in terms of the domestic
constraints that follow them around as
they go to these meetings around the war
world interestingly enough there are
probably more constraints on the
Democratic leaders than there are on
those that come from more autocratic
societies where they don't face domestic
political pressures at the same level in
some cases but in any case I think it's
important to remember that when you have
20 liters coming to a meeting like this
you're not going to have just one agenda
you're going to have 20 agendas and the
challenge in many respects is how do we
distill all these various interests and
agendas down to one thing one agenda
that everyone can agree on and that can
serve as the basis for action moving
forward and it's the question actually
distillation it may be rather than we
need to synthesize you'll find in terms
of our presenters and some of the
written materials that are available to
you there are there are very different
proposals about the best way to move
forward and so it's going to be very
thought-provoking I think what kind of
constraints are there on on agreement or
on moving forward to renew globalization
there are institutional constraints and
you'll hear some about that their
political constraints that's pretty
obvious I think and there are also
psychological constraints for how we can
even talk about some of these issues
that are so complex in a rational way do
we need a societal or international
consensus for example about levels of
risk you're going to hear a lot about
risk in the next several days is this
meeting goes forward and there you're
going to hear a lot about the risks of
the market system or the risks that are
inherent in the market system but what
you're going to hear from our panelists
and and also perhaps in some of the
discussion is about the risks to the
market system and are their actions that
are potentially going to be taken that
that actually threaten the free
enterprise market system and could do
harm to that system politicians often
talk about eliminating
risk I think you've all heard that in
the news well economists know that if
you eliminate risk you're also going to
eliminate growth and progress and the
question is finding the right balance
you can you really can eliminate risk in
a system but there is a cost to doing
that and we have to identify what those
costs are and then determine how much
risk we want to accept in order to
achieve the maximum amount of progress
there are important issues of psychology
of equity involved in this discussion
and hopefully we can get into some of
that in greater detail but the question
is how can we have an intelligent
conversation about risk and how to
manage risk in the international system
and in the economic system and then
another issue that I want to raise and
this is one on which I think you'll find
all of your panelists here agreeing is
that one of the biggest threats to the
renewal of globalization is the
resurgence of protectionism and this is
actually a bigger question it's
presented most often as pressure from
from labor unions or from firms but but
I think the bigger question is how do we
insulate governments from the pressures
of privileged groups or elites to
maintain the status quo to maintain the
status quo in which they enjoy existing
privileges when people come and ask for
protection it's it's never a request for
a change it's a request to keep things
the same as they are are as they were in
the very recent past the very concept of
protectionism is to protect the status
quo and what is already there and there
are a lot of pressures to do that
particularly at a time of accelerated
change and one of the things you heard
from our first panel this morning was
how the pace of change is accelerating
in our societies and that creates a lot
of pressures on people and a lot of
pressures on politicians
my idea as a free market economist would
be don't create these situations in the
first place if you give government too
much power allow government to be too
intrusive in the marketplace this
creates pressures on businesses to
engage in rent seeking activity where
they come and ask for privileges from
governments rather than concentrating on
how to make their businesses more
productive and of course the larger
government involvement is in economies
also the greater the opportunities and
the temptations for corrupt Behavior now
our the solutions to this they're
wide-ranging I want to give you just a
few that came from the writings of the
invited participants who are not on our
panel but who did participate in
producing this book and they and they're
all over the block Robert Hutchings for
example talks about a grand global
bargain that involves actions by the g20
in areas of reform of the financial
system managing anti-globalization
backlash energy security climate change
nuclear proliferation in the reform of
global institutions it's virtually the
agenda that the g20 have set for
themselves and his idea is that you
should have action by the g20 in all of
these areas he talks about President
Dwight Eisenhower's old idea that if you
meet a problem that you can't deal with
the proper solution is to enlarge the
problem so that you bring more people
into more people are involved in dealing
with that problem and so this would be
the the big government solution if you
will to the problems that we face on the
other hand we have some people writing
in this book that have very simple
solution Steve Forbes says don't worry
so much about the institutions but just
create a stable monetary in
Steve would do it through returning to
the gold standard actually he believes
if you did that the market would be able
to work out the issues by the same token
Steven Krasner writes that things that
it's important to remember that things
aren't really so bad we brought millions
of people out of poverty over the last
two decades a great power relationships
have never been more benign in Steve's
views he talks about the design of aid
programs and other interventions so that
you promote democratic accountability
well maybe this is the way forward for
people we've got Bruce bueno de mesquita
who writes that of the importance that
of governance along the same lines how
do leaders retain power these leaders
come here all 20 of them for many of
them their primary concern is is perhaps
the next election or how do they
maintain themselves in power many
decisions they make or programs they put
forward or at least going to have one
eye on the question of maintaining
themselves in power and Bruce talks
about the difference between countries
where you have small groups of elite
elites that have to be satisfied by the
government and that's the case where the
government may be the main dispenser of
economic largesse or wealth in a society
and he recommends that we try to come up
with policies that would broaden the
coalition's that support governments and
leaders and and so that there the
government gets out of the business of
dispensing favors both economic and
political to to maintain themselves in
power and finally John Miller has
written and this is just the most
important general point that we face
that markets are complex systems with a
lot of feedbacks both positive and
negative and the straightforward kind of
scientific reductionism that we in the
policy world most often
try to use in solving problems where we
where we try to identify a single cause
and effect that that may not be possible
or appropriate in the market system
because of the complexity of the issues
that are involved therein so again I
recommend the booklet to you I think
you'll find a lot of wisdom there in I'm
now going to turn to the panelists and
ask each of them to just in two or three
minutes give us a brief overview of the
insights that they bring to this
discussion of the constraints that we
are facing in maintaining or renewing
globalization around the world and I'd
like to start with Karen Skinner who
with a couple of collaborators wrote a
very interesting paper about the some of
the structural issues of these groupings
the g20 and that in which leaders meet
and cooperate Karen action I'm one of
the hosts of the conference and I wanted
to take just a second to thank a number
of people but as I wrote the list that
it kept growing and I will risk not
mentioning some important people so I
want to thank everyone who helped put
this together both of the Atlantic
Council side and Carnegie Mellon and in
particular to thank my department head
John Miller for allowing me to snatch a
large part of the the staff of the
department without his consent to work
on this event I see them running around
I didn't know that was going to happen
today but i will take turn to the main
point to give some context of the g20
and my co-authors and I try to think
about this meeting in a historical
context and in terms of the challenges
this ever growing body faces I don't
know if you know the fact but the g20
started as the library group in March
1973 the secretary of the Treasury at
the time George Shultz recognizing that
the economic crisis would deepen in the
aftermath of the breakdown of bread and
wood system by then in 73 the world's
major currencies were floating against
each other there was an impending oil
prices the OPEC first major OPEC crisis
happened later that year he invited his
opposite numbers from France Germany in
the UK to meet informally and President
Nixon said why don't you use the
basement library of the White House they
dubbed themselves the library group and
it was supposed to be an informal
gathering within three years it had
become the g7 and was holding its second
summit they included Canada Italy and
Japan to expand the group and they were
issuing communicate something they had
promised themselves they would never do
by the end of the 1990s the independent
state of Russia joined and it became the
g8 as a result of the Asian economic
crises of that same period the g20 was
formed to give developing nations an
opportunity to interact with the top
industrialized nations in a similar
forum so these organizations have the g
system has expanded far beyond its an
original intent which was to be an
informal meeting place to talk about
talk about ways to coordinate
international economic policy now the
g20 is the g20 which shows out of the
original library group and is kind of a
parallel organization to the g8
addresses economic issues in its
official title as a organization focused
on central bankers and finance ministers
but leaders have decided to attend
starting in november of last year it
became a leaders forum so we now have
presidents and prime ministers in
addition to finance ministers and
central bankers which means that every
issue is on the
including political security climate
change not just issues of economic
coordinate coordination in addition to
the g8 the g7 which still exists the g8
with Russia the g20 which includes again
developed and developing nations there's
a new g5 I'm a professor can anyone here
tell me what the new g5 is well there's
a nude so the g5 professor silver
preserve ski I'm sure knows I'm includes
Mexico if I get it right Brazil India
China and what's the other in China
India Russia there so there's a new g5
plus Egypt there's well I don't know
about the g2 so there's so many of these
well there's a new g5 in particular that
attended the GM the recent g8 meeting in
Italy this summer and it's called the g5
plus Egypt the g5 plus Egypt is making a
case along with support from some of the
g8 members especially Italy France and
Germany to join the g8 to make it the
g14 so probably within a two years we
will have AG 14 the old g8 the old g7
the g20 some are trying to make the g20
the g-33 and then some are in fact
arguing for the g 1 92 which is to
expand the jesus the whole membership of
the United Nations the reason I mention
all of this in the history is to say
that the larger the system grows the
more relevant it actually becomes
because it's an informal body if you go
on
all these entities and again that's not
what the library group won it but they
all kept their own website and they
issue communicates actually first day of
the summer if you go boy website you
will see they say that their informal
organization with no Secretariat no
permanent staff no office building that
sounds a little dangerous at the
international level for all of problems
with the UN there is some accountability
there the problem with this system is
that it's growing so large to meet some
real demands and some who demands are
important from the developing world
Mexico and Spain for example in terms of
GDP defined in terms of power purchasing
parodius exceeds Canada and trying to
exceeds all of the members of the g20
except the European Union as an entity
and the United States so there is a real
case just based on economic power but if
you have a huge informal body that's
informal with no account real
accountability to anyone making
decisions that influence what the real
organizations like the UN the IMF the
World Bank the WTO actually do then it
leads to confusion and mission creep and
a lot of things it's hard for states to
know exactly what to do and who their
real allies are on a given issue also
many states have overlapping memberships
everyone's in the UN of course but some
members of these various geez that I've
just mentioned Earl and other new
organizations such as the brick Brazil
Russia India China and then the SEO the
Shanghai Cooperation Organization but
they're addressing the same issues so
you have states that are
literally in two or three international
organizations addressing the same issues
but coming down on different sides of
the same problems so it's somewhat of a
confusing situation in which we find
ourselves internationally trying to
respond to the aspirations of the
developing world and to the facts that
too long for too long during the Cold
War a handful of states like the library
who dictate it to the rest of the world
what international economic policy
should be I'm a professor so I don't
have to have a solution I can just
identify a problem so I've identified I
think what is a major challenge of these
organizations I think it's useful to
have conversations but that's ultimately
all that they may actually be able to
achieve because decision making in an
informal structure where the decisions
have to actually have to be deployed
within more traditional institutions is
a formula I think for not getting very
much done there's a lot more I could say
about the political divisions within the
g20 this week on issues of Iran
Afghanistan on climate change some of
the most important issues facing the
world now they're deep disagreement in
New York going on in all of these in
particular because the u.s. is in a
major reevaluation of its policies on
each of these issues in Afghanistan in
particular the Obama administration may
have its second turnaround on
Afghanistan in six months that does not
lead provide the context for great
leadership but I'm going to turn the mic
over to some of my other colleagues and
Q&A we can go into deeper discussion
tension that she's identified between
inclusiveness bringing the greatest
number of countries are people into the
discussions on these very important
issues and into the process of managing
them to the extent we want to do that
internationally there's a tension
between that and the efficiency and the
difficulties in achieving consensus that
you get with ever larger group
of countries I'd like to turn now to
john herman on our panel who has some
very direct hands-on experience in
helping the US government prepare for
g20 meetings and some of the problems
that you have in going beyond rhetoric
and turning things into actual action
that can achieve results in the world
John yeah Thank You Terry again my name
is john herman and with the law firm of
kelley drye and warren wash in
washington DC and as Terry mentioned I
served at the end of the Bush
administration and into the first few
months of the Obama administration and
was involved in the preparations for the
November summit in Washington that
President Bush hosted as well as in
President Obama's preparations for the
London summit in April I guess just to
start the ball rolling just one quick
point i'll make about the the topic of
our panel today of renewing or
reinvigorating globalism is what a tough
environment it is right now that leaders
are facing with the uncertainty created
by the financial crisis and the
subsequent slowing of the global economy
it's a very very difficult sell in many
countries to advance trade and
investment liberalization so I think you
will see that you'll see general
comments by leaders and I think Karen
was suggesting what what is really
important now is moving beyond the
general statements to commitments so in
terms of why we're all here today that
the g20 there was there was a fair
amount of thought given to
to the leaders that President Bush dis
ultimately decided to invite to
Washington last November one of the key
considerations was looking for an
existing grouping so that you had a
clearly defined set of countries and
leaders that would be included in the
meeting and and based on the work of the
g20 in the aftermath of the asian
financial crisis in the late 90s and
based on the composition of that group a
decision was made that the the g20 would
be an appropriate basis for moving
forward I think people went into the g20
summit very aware of the difficulties
that would be associated with building
consensus where you had basically moved
from largely what was a group of
industrialized democracies in the g7 and
g8 into a g20 which had a much much
different composition and I thank you
over the course of the last two summits
you've seen some of those disagreements
surface none have been really inhibited
progress but but you've seen comments by
leaders in the press leading up to the
various summits for instance
disagreements over the importance or
necessity of domestic stimulus in the
lead-up to the London summit and April
with the United States in the UK in
China all having come forward with
significant stimulus programs French in
the Germans and some others perhaps
questioning the necessity of going
forward with programs that were as large
as a percentage of GDP as some of the
other nations you've also seen
disagreements on the scope of financial
regulation in reform how aggressive
should
should national and potentially
international regulators be and a final
one that I'll mentioned quickly is
participation one of the significant
outcomes in the London summit was a
reinvigoration of funds for the
International Monetary Fund and
commitments on quota reform it's widely
thought that when those reforms are in
place they will lead to increased
representation for the emerging major
developing countries and will result in
diminished participation potentially by
a number of European countries so you've
got the tension there with a with a
larger pool in terms of the summit this
week and the significance of the g20
going forward I think what will be
significant is how the g20 transitions
from what up till now has been a very
large focus on responding to the
financial crisis and and the threat to
growth to what comes next what comes
after the crisis has passed obviously
you've seen talk about imbalances from
many of senior officials in the Obama
administration I think that potentially
could lead to a transition to other
issues climate change food security I
think it's important to remember that at
the summit this week the g20 will have
met at the leader level three times in
less than a year you know November last
year april of this year in September of
this year normally within that span you
would have one g8 meeting and I think
the the need to put together an agenda
on a very short time basis has prevented
perhaps some wider thinking
engagement within the g20 on some of
these issues and hopefully we'll see
that in the time to come I guess just
one last point I'll make is talking
about the proliferation of G's and
whether the g20 will become the new g8
and perhaps supplant some of this that
too will be interesting to see there
I've seen some reports in the press that
there's already some discussion about
perhaps having Canada host the next g20
leaders meeting early next year that the
Koreans in their capacity as the chair
of the g20 next year would would be
engaged in some of the preparations so
it will be very interesting to see if
the g20 does in fact supplant the g8
thank you very much John now we're going
to take the discussion in a slightly
different direction our next two
panelists have looked at specific issues
their broad issues they're very
important issues one is the financial
crisis the other is climate change and
have them give us a brief discussion of
how these various constraints are
impacting on their particular issues and
how the leaders might look to overcome
them let's start with the financial
crisis and mansoor de la me I come from
the World Bank and so forth at least the
world binding doesn't have the
designation of geez and if I would look
to alphabetic you know game to find two
letters I would say you and be you in
stands for universalism because the bank
has memberships of all countries 186
countries and d4 the mission of the bank
which is development and poverty
reduction in terms of the comments I
like to highlight three issues which i
think is very important particularly as
we look beyond the current crisis
that kinda uptick in the global gross
that we see first one in my position
I've been in a monitoring these markets
over the past two years I'm kind of
coming out of this crisis a little bit
more optimistic that many people have
taken I d'accord very well during the
period of sep tember through September
2008 through march two thousand nine
when we saw the world economy virtually
falling many countries aided in deep
recession or moving toward recession
with some markets equity markets bond
markets trading on panic under the
fundamentals with unemployment rising
and we saw obviously great concern
expressed by commentators by leaders of
different countries and that really
affect more than anything else the
confidence the confidence of consumers
the confidence investors and when you
have a confidence problem then you have
a serious problem it's goes beyond
economical social durable and if i
quoted the reason that this crisis was
so deep was so severe compared to
previous crises that we have a long
history was because confidence was so
shattered december on people lost
confidence in the institution people
lost confidence in the Holy structural
global finance and I think one of the
key challenges moving forward is ready
how to restore confidence of the public
at large in the overall governance of
financial markets and economic system
the second point which I like to make is
that looking again on the economic
saying yes we do see a positive
developments we see recovery is picking
up in Asia particularly we see signs and
grows in the United States and other
European countries and we see that's
real production exports picking up some
steam but when you look at the long-term
development consequences of this crisis
this is something that is going to be
with us for many years to go and g20 so
far has been more
representative middle-income countries
and in the Australian countries and the
perspective that I think the bank is
putting in this agenda the gee Tony this
tomorrow is the poorest countries is the
low-income countries historically
whenever we see a global sharks economic
shocks what idea from outside or from
the developing countries themselves the
poverty is affected very severely this
time around we are estimating close to
maybe 89 million people more could be
added to that Drake poverty it's very
important when you look at the human
aspects of these crises it's worthy
their governments particularly in
important countries that they don't have
the resources they don't have the kind
of microgram accounted fiscal balances
they generally tend to cut expenditure
which is very fundamental to development
they cut education expenditure they cut
health education they can social safety
net education and these are the ones
that has much longer term implications
we have for instance saying that
generally more nutrition among girls
become much more severe than the boys
it's not because they gives biologically
wicked and avoids and fight the girls
tend to be a stronger than the boys in
many countries but it just because
families try to protect the boys we saw
in the girls we see for instance poverty
indices in the East Asia crisis it took
another 10 years that they could reach
delivered before the crisis I think that
is a very important part of the agenda
that has to be put in the table we
estimated close two countries make up 20
billion dollars out of those soldiers
and core indicators and that's why our
president Bob Zurich has been calling
for a responsible globalization for a
sustainable globalization I think the
economic fundamental forces in play are
going to make globalized and reality
whether we like it or not the question
is not the fortunate economic that
pushing us to the normalization it to
extent to which we have choices we have
policy instruments that we can change
their form of it then
ho-8 they become a response Megan
organization the Teddy issue that kind
of mentioned the question of the g's and
if I actually going back a little bit
more there were just 77 the soca
non-aligned nations and during the
crisis people talking about G to China
and the United States and the two
countries that had economic muscle to
pull the you know by constant but
somehow we have to come with some grapes
with this G equation with G business I
mean after all the whole international
system today is going and the
significant what record is shift in
economic balance you're moving away from
the big 60 in the shredder countries
towards more developing countries in
terms of economic power there's like
economic resources in terms difficult at
the population demographic fighters
their old signal that much more strongly
road for developing countries and the
question is how best can be accommodated
how best we can can do to manage this
transition its capital papers and I
myself I my other colleagues have been
writing we are we talking about a
multipolar world economic system that's
basically we are moving away from one or
two pole economics maybe multiple is it
your port one port could be financed in
the BRICS countries that today are
becoming very important China could be
maybe some of the oil exporting
countries in some combination but the
key question is that as you go towards
mitcham of multiplicity economic powers
economic systems then it's going to pose
a major problem for the whole
establishment for the whole system how
birth sched we can manage it in the
monetary area over the past couple
months we have seen that probably
whenever it a Chinese official talks
about moving away from the US dollars
diversifying the investment in other
currencies what is the next day's
affected quite important and with good
reason china today is the largest
creditor of the united states government
today holds the largest among the US
government debt and obviously whenever
they decide talk about this effect
market but the same
time the United States is the largest
market for Chinese exports therefore
there's a commonality of interest which
binds these two countries to get it you
could look at these community engines in
the broader sense and I think all of
that brings the pictured is the
connectedness that we see the world
economy but what is really important
moving forward how we make this is not
so much as Teddy mentioned killing the
globalization I think this beyond of it
power anyway not as strong forces are
moving as making the skin organization
the sensible I'll irresponsible thank
you ms w thank you mother or thank you
very much I'm particularly interested in
your comments about investor confidence
because economists all know that
expectations have a way of becoming self
fulfilling in terms of economic activity
and I'm afraid it's no coincidence that
the onset of this financial crisis
coincided with an election season a very
long election season in the united
states in which the American public at
least were bombarded with negative
messages about both the government of
the United States and even the system
the economic system of the United States
and ultimately the electorate seemed to
lose confidence in both and that
coincided precisely with the onset of
this of this recession but now I want to
turn on the same theme particularly
talking about some of the psychological
factors that impinge on the leaders and
the decision-making process and ask
George Loewenstein to to talk to us a
little bit about global warming and his
research in those areas thank you let me
before I begin my comments say that I
would say that the onset of the economic
difficulties preceded the election
season by quite a bit but in any case
I'm going to in my essay I talk about
the applications of behavioral economics
to global climate change behavioral
economics is itself a field that exam
implications of psychology to economics
now I think that behavioral economics
has a lot of insights to offer in terms
of helping to explain the problem of
global climate change there's a lot of
psychology there the part of the problem
is that the consequences of our behavior
are delayed the consequences of our
behavior are amorphous our behavior when
anything that we do is a drop in the
bucket and we generally have problems
dealing with drop in the bucket type
behaviors like for example one potato
chip isn't going to make a spat and
driving to work one extra time isn't
going to affect the global climate
change problem so I think behavioral
economics as well as economics itself
has a lot of implications to offer for
understanding why global climate change
is such a difficult problem to deal with
if there's one if there's one main
insight that it has to offer however I
believe it has to do with something
called the self-serving bias and the
self-serving bias is the idea that we
tend to confuse what's in our
self-interest with what's fair so if you
ask for example if you go to a couple a
married couple they don't have to be
married living together and you ask them
what percentage of the housework ask
each member of the household what
percentage of the house work do you do
the number ads too much more than a
hundred percent people tend to see
things from their own perspective there
was a really nice experiment done years
ago by Roth and Myrna Han they took two
people and they said here are 20 tokens
and one of these tokens is going to win
a prize your task is to divide these
tokens between the two of you and if you
can divide the tokens between the two of
you then we'll hold the will hold the
lottery and one of you will get the
prize the rub was that for one person
the prize was five dollars and for the
other person the prize was twenty
dollars now so the
think about it from the perspective of
the person who's going to win twenty
dollars what's the natural way to divide
the tokens well the natural ways each of
us should get 10 tokens right isn't that
what's fair divide the tokens equally
well the person who was going to get
five dollars if they won the lottery
said the natural way to divide the
tokens is that we each have an expected
value of winning so I should get a lot
more tokens to equalize our expected
value of winning and so it was this
difference between the two parties that
made it very difficult for them to
settle the settle this very simple
negotiation and I think this is a
metaphor for climate change if if people
have a hard time solving that problem
with a bunch of all they have to do is
split tokens and there's two prizes
think about the difficulty of trying to
decide on emission caps for different
countries of the world so China is going
to say you know we're still we're
growing but we're still poor and you us
you've been polluting for years and
years its part the part of the reason
why you're so rich why should we limit
our emissions at all it's our turn you
should do all of the you should look mom
do all the work of limiting emissions
and the u.s. is going to say forget it
you know we're not coming to the table
unless everybody limit submissions and
so these self-serving biases are
probably the I would say are probably
the number one impediment to solving the
problem of global climate change now at
the same time however that on a
self-serving bias it may be the main
impediment to solve and global climate
change it also maybe offer the main
solution and here's the reason when
people view things in self-serving terms
they tend to think that their
perspective is the neutral perspective
that would be shared by a third party so
the fight the person who's getting five
dollars would think that anybody would
say it's fair to equalize expected
values the person who is getting twenty
dollars would say anyone would say it's
fair to split the tips
10 tips for each person and the result
of that is because people think that
their perspective is on fairness is
going to be shared it's going to make
them more willing to accept outside
arbitration because they're going to
people are going to or people are
nations are going to think that
arbitrators are going to side with them
so I believe that the main problem of a
self-serving bias the main problem
involving climate change is the
self-serving bias but it also offers the
solution which is the self-serving bias
is likely to make people open to the
idea of kind of kicking the problem
upstairs to some kind of neutral
arbitrator thank you George thank you
very much that's really interesting fact
I found your paper to be one of the most
interesting in the book and and one of
the things that it emphasized for me was
just the importance of trying for all of
us to try to expand our perspectives to
the greatest possible extent so that we
understand the biases and the the needs
of others and can try to incorporate
those into any of the solutions that we
propose to any of these pressing
problems so now we're going to make this
even more particular we started out with
the structural issues then we looked at
a couple of particular political or
economic issues and now I want to take a
brief look at a couple of specific
countries and to do that let's start
with Steven brotman who has some views
about Germany in the current crisis
before I hi I'm a professor of German
here at Carnegie Mellon University in
the Department of Modern Languages and I
work primarily on 20th century German
cultural history but and my essay in the
book is about Germany but before I I
talk about Germany specifically I just
want to say that I very much agree with
monsewer about the need for global
cooperation I think it's increasingly
clear clear that there are all sorts of
problems that the world is face
today that that one country simply can't
you know even a country as powerful as
the United States simply can't can't
address alone and coming out of what you
were saying also George I think it's a
question of the tokens and how do you
solve I mean it's all about cooperation
I think and so I think it's really good
actually that the g20 process exists I
think it's great that the leaders are
are coming and getting together to meet
I think it would be actually quite bad
if in a situation like the one that
we're facing they were not getting
together to talk about things so we
can't do it alone we need to work
together we need to cooperate another
thing I want to point that I want to
make is that we can't do everything and
this is a truism but politics is always
the art of the possible and so you have
to set priorities and that means that
you can do some things and there are
other things that realistically you
can't do a third point I want to make is
and this is a very important point that
we often forget when we're talking about
politics and economics is that culture
matters about 12 13 years ago an
important political scientist at Harvard
named Samuel Huntington wrote a book
called The Clash of Civilizations this
book was an important analysis of the
world situation in the 1990s after the
collapse of the berlin wall and the end
of the Cold War system and you can argue
about many of the points that Huntington
makes in that book but one of the
important points that he makes is that
is that culture matters there are
various established cultures around the
world and we need to be sensitive to
those cultures and to the particularity
of those cultures and that involves
religion that involves history that
involves a whole lot of things and we
should be thinking about that as we face
the g20 process another point I wasn't
paid before talking about Germany is
that reality matters there was a person
of the Bush administration a few years
ago who said that because the United
States is so powerful we can kind of
create our own reality that's not true
reality matters and we have to confront
it
right we can't just create our own
obviously we can have an impact on
reality but we don't create reality and
then the final point I want to make is
that is that history matters it's very
helpful in looking at all these all
these issues to have some sense of
historical perspective in thinking about
the global crisis now the economic
situation it's very important to know
about what happened before this is not
the first time the capitalism has faced
a crisis I'm sure it won't be the last
and so it's important in addressing
these issues to have some knowledge of
that and then to move into the question
of Germany the final point I want to
make is that allies matter and and
Germany has been an ally of the United
States now for 60 years the federal
republic of germany was founded out of
the ruins of World War two horrible
catastrophic history that Germany really
brought upon itself and amazingly enough
and this is a history that we Americans
I think can truly be proud of the
federal republic really sort of pulled
itself up with our help and established
itself as one of the most important
powerful economies and countries in the
world and this is something that the
Germans can be proud of it's also
something that I think we Americans can
really be proud of and it's as a history
that we need to keep in mind when I make
the point that culture matters one of
the things that happened in Germany is
that you had this country that really
had not known a successful democracy and
that we as the United States helped that
democracy to come into being that
democracy is now celebrating its 60th
anniversary and so I think it's
important for us Americans when we look
out there at the world and think about
what our cultural values are and the
kinds of things that we want to
accomplish that we particularly look at
our European allies and in particularly
look at a country like Germany the
world's fourth largest economy in a
country that over the past
a decade or so has really developed a
good amount of a fair amount of goodwill
in the world and I think Germany in many
ways is is a natural ally for us one
point that I'll make final point about
Germany somebody mentioned the fact that
a lot of these leaders are going to be
facing elections and literally angela
merkel the chancellor of germany is
facing an election on sunday so when she
leaves pittsburgh to fly back to Germany
it's basically one final day of
campaigning and then she's up for
reelection chances are that she will win
reelection great thank you very much
Stephen and picking up on your history
point I think our next presenter can you
dork any Mendes well we'll talk to us a
little bit about a historical anomaly
and perhaps the importance as we move
forward of fixing or at least not
repeating some of the mistakes of the
past in some remarks about Cuba thank
you I am also a professor of Hispanic
studies in the Department of Modern
Languages and I'm very grateful to be
here I think yes history lessons are
important and one thing that I need to
say about Cuban the United States is
that people don't realize that the
histories the shared history of our two
countries did not begin 47 or 50 years
ago or even a hundred years ago but
rather that our connection with Cuba
goes back even to the period of the
American Revolution and the United
States once it was formed had a regular
presence in Cuba as did Cubans in the
United States but getting to the point
of the last 47 or 50 years of policy
that the United States has maintained
with some changes towards Cuba and given
the opportunity to discuss a topic that
I don't usually mention very much which
is economics and and policy because i'm
more of a student of culture and history
I felt it was a great opportunity to
examine a good reason why the United
States
needs to rethink its policy towards Cuba
and needs to find ways to re-engage with
Cuba in a sensible and
non-confrontational manner and in the
context of the meetings of the g20 and
by the way Cuba is not a member of any
of those G groupings that you've
mentioned i think that the countries of
the european union and the other members
of the g20 are in an excellent position
to provide solid varied models by which
the united states can engage
economically with cuba which is probably
going to bring about greater change in
cuba than any of the policies that have
been followed thus far by our government
curiously though even though we've had a
an embargo an actual trading with the
enemy act which has prohibited the
United States from officially doing
business with Cuba it turns out that the
private sector in the United States has
that has been doing business with Cuba
and as we speak there are companies in
Pennsylvania and in Florida and in Idaho
and in many other states of the union
that currently do business with Cuba
which i think is an enormous
contradiction given the fact that the
government still has an official policy
that prohibits that and the other thing
is to highlight the fact that actually
the policy that the United States has
maintained over the last 47 or 50 years
is something that was designed to
isolate a government a regime but the
lasting effects of that isolation have
affected the Cuban people much more than
it had has the Cuban state and I think
that this human sense of responsibility
is something that exact applicable here
it turns out that there's very little
information available to the American
public about what goes on in Cuba and
in particular what economic benefits the
United States might reap by engaging
with Cuba economically of course the
natural tendency is to think about
tourism and it's certainly true and I
wrote about in my essay how much how not
the millions but perhaps billions of
dollars that a tourist industry and open
tourist industry to Cuba would generate
for the United States it would generate
at least 12,000 jobs in the United
States right off the bat and there are
many trade travel companies all around
the world that are already engaging in
this in Spain in Italy Canada and so on
and the United States is going to be is
not going to be a primary player when it
even attempts to to initiate these
relations but certainly should have a
place at that table another thing that
people don't realize is due to this lack
of information is that actually these
two countries have been collaborating on
certain issues over the decades despite
the official and public lack of
negotiation or of even conversation one
of them has been related to the weather
and the fact is that the u.s. and Cuba
have been engaged in a very close
working relationship for probably going
back to the 70s through the National
Hurricane Center and Cuba is a country
that has an enormous amount of
experience in dealing with this type of
weather phenomenon and also in avoiding
loss of life and property and also in
recovering from such disasters and most
people would say that knowing that that
the u.s. could learn lessons on how to
deal with these disasters which occur
every year every summer another thing
that people don't realize it even
recently the u.s. and Cuba have been
meeting may be meeting face-to-face to
normalize mail service between the two
countries this is not something that
gets pressed things that get press have
to do with
no groupings in Miami or with whether
Fidel are all are really actually in
control of government there but people
don't realize things like the
collaboration that does exist between
the two countries or the fact that
legislation is been pending in Congress
again that would lift the ban on all US
citizens being able to travel to Cuba
not just Cuban Americans there have been
recent changes under the Obama
administration that have relaxed the
impact of the travel ban on Cuban
American families and Cuban families on
the island because now Cuban Americans
are able to send more money and send
more goods but what we don't know for
example is that companies like Dish
Network I have just applied with the FCC
trying to get permission to broadcast
into Cuba or that there was a recent
business deal that took millions of
American made cell phones into Cuba to
facilitate communication between Cuban
American families and Cuban families on
the island once a year people are
reminded that the United Nations General
Assembly votes on its opinion of the US
embargo of the United States and for 17
years it has voted negatively and feels
that the US needs to change its policy
for many reasons not just economic
reasons and the u.s. Council of Bishops
was recently in Cuba and as quoted as
saying that the u.s. and Cuba need to
listen to better angels because 50 years
of hostilities have gotten us a lot of
pain and suffering but not much else and
the other thing that I wanted to say is
that Cuba has recently charged is trying
to negotiate a commercial license with
18 private firms in the US because Cuba
produces a great deal of biomedical
products important products recently
this particular effort concerns a
medication color pepper brought p which
has drastically reduced the need for
amputations and
these patients Cuba has one of the
lowest HIV infection rates and whereas
earlier on followed the protocol
followed by most developed countries
because it found it difficult to get
interference and so on develop reduced
in the United States became very
entrepreneurial and started developing
its own antiretrovirals and interference
which are now on the market in at least
40 countries biotech is actually a very
big field and biomedical is a very big
field in Cuba these products are sold as
i said in over 40 countries and they're
at least 180 of these products and at
least 1300 applications have been
patented patented for Cuba and different
nations so this is this economic miracle
that could occur if the US were to
engage with Cuba economically which
would bring around tremendous
development for both countries and also
mend mend the lives of millions of
people on both sides of the Straits
would be a reflection of a truly global
view of engaging economically with
countries all around the world and so
that's basically what I wanted to say
thank you very much okay thank you very
much appreciate that perspective and it
certainly gives us a vivid understanding
of the political constraints on an issue
that that any leader may face and
certainly the US administration of any
party faces a lot of political
constraints in terms of how to deal with
Cuba now last but not least we have a
real privilege of having a unique
perspective on our panel Erica man has a
wide and varied background and brings a
lot to the discussion but I'd like to
focus most on her background is a member
of the European Parliament and as a as a
politician herself she is able to bring
a perspective to to what's going on in
these discussions and and I would ask
her to give us some insight as to how
the politicians that are meeting here
this week can get a handle on all these
issues
and move forward in a constructive way
into the future erica was remember to
the European Parliament for 15 years i'm
from germany and i was the speaker for
my political group Social Democrat
Social Democratic family on trade I
think what is interesting to observe I
think it's in it's a really a phenol
main bitches I think goes much beyond
that what we do understand to out now
because what we see it's only you know
an observation you know when leaders
meet and how they sit together and how
they discuss policy issues but what is
of course much more important and much
more relevant is to understand is what
is behind it what is driving them why
why actually do we suddenly have a g20
and what is a queuing what is what is
changing and the world context and I
mean being around i'm covering trade for
so many years i have seen this having
something similar actually in the abroad
way around because i mean the first
round which i experienced it was around
primarily undertaken by the
industrialized world of course the
developing countries they were sitting
on the table and on certain issues they
have a debating certain topics but it
was a different world and now if you see
I mean we started years ago the the
latest World Trade wound and we
continued the Doha Development long we
continue and we continue to negotiate
and if you see why and if you ask
yourself why is this the case and the
answer is very simple because you have
so much more interest from developing
countries in certain issues and I like
they like to I mean a develop and define
their own destiny they're not interested
any longer that much that their interest
is expressed by others but I like
actually to understand what is important
and what is relevant for their own
country and federal nation-state and for
their own citizens and not everything is
obvious many things are unclear so it is
not the case that for more
of the political leaders neither in
India or in Europe I mean it's not a
developing country you just take it as
an example or in Africa or in China it
is obvious you know what is right or
what is wrong is it better to integrate
an agriculture market or is it more
important actually to work on food
security in your country is it better to
buy into land into Africa like China is
to is doing because they foresee that in
the future ever be not enough food
production in their own country if they
don't buy land right now in Africa or is
it better to go into GMO production or
is it better to go for organic or is it
better to like India is arguing in
certain cases that you need a
traditional production and and sort of
many answers and the same what is true
for us and what is true for most of us
it's true for political leaders you have
to find the answer but how to find the
answer it's the it is very complicated
and it's a very complicated world we are
living in because if you have six
members on a family or you have 24
members on the family on the table or 18
members and in a family on the table it
changes the dynamic and it gives you you
have more questions and you have my
answers and it becomes less obvious what
you want to do and what you want to
achieve and this is the the the
difficulties and of course you have much
friends as well you have not a single
twins and because of the internet and
because of the interconnection and the
interrelationship we are all living in
India all-embracing you know one single
answer which you think one day it's the
best one the next you know you you we do
not equal 0 you somebody tells you hey
very way I found you know some other
research which is telling the opposite
so use the city again on the JV that's
okay what's white what is wrong now I
think the most important is and this is
what i see that finally be allowed this
to happen because it was very difficult
over the last two years it was different
and still is sometimes and the world
trade talks and it's
to ng20 because there's a lot of
resistance you know who is actually the
most capable of giving the best and the
most capable and most intelligent and
most sophisticated answer and I think it
will be important in all of those
international arrangement and
environments finally to accept that the
that there might be not a single answer
there might be many many answers it
might be probably not a single most
perfect one for their financial crisis
and forty outcome of dependents required
if you are evaluates there are certain
aspects which need to be aligned and
which need to be coherent but the answer
might be a little bit different in India
than in the United States or in Latin
America because the markets are a bit
different in markets integration is
different the neighbors are different
you know their markets opening it's not
obvious the same so I think this
probably would be there something
important to look what we have what kind
of similarities we have where we need to
find common ounces and where we can
allow a differentiation because they're
differentiations might provide you know
better you know relevant information and
prevention of future crises as well I'm
very hopeful i must say i think the
trend for integration continues and
usually it is obviously case if you look
back into history the it's always first
the economy which integrates then you
will see citizens are follow and then
the last which will follow deterrence
usually are the politicians this is this
is it is true so I'm very hopeful I
would be surprised if this trend will
not continue and we will not see that
politicians will finally start working
together understanding how important it
is because let's face it if mine if they
will be not capable of providing common
answers and and looking into some some
kind of crisis control not not you know
perfect control but some kind of
understanding how a crisis can be
managed what you learn from it
is it foreseeable how can they you know
discuss failure but can one learn from
failure etc etc then I think if this is
not going it is not going to happen but
i'm very hopeful this is going to happen
so it's a to work on a negative 2 now it
doesn't make any sense because i'm truly
certain we will we will see more co
cooperation in the future and i'm more
willingness in global leaders to
actually to follow and to make it
workable that we that they will actually
define the their their agenda I'm and
putting certain this is true for foot
security very true for the climate
change debate it may be not perfect but
come out comes out of it and we
shouldn't look for perfect solution it's
not important the past is important you
know the right way the right course is
important naughty you know perfectness
in the in a single answer on a single
meeting on a single outcome it is not
important so i'm i am very positive and
i would be very surprised if Eva not see
something relevant coming out of the g20
meeting thank you very much Erica I
started out talking about 20 liters with
20 different agendas and Erica wraps up
talking about the multiplicity of
solutions that may be possible to these
problems around the world but in all
this varied information that you've
heard here today and I hope we've
challenged some of your assumptions and
and perhaps opened your eyes to some
different ways of looking at issues I'd
like to see if there's at least one
thing on which all of our panelists can
in fact agree and I would posit that
every single person on this panel
believes that one of the outcomes of the
g20 meeting needs to be a strong
statement by the leaders rejecting
protectionism and I would wonder if
anybody disagrees with that up here
George right include an end to
agricultural subsidies certainly a form
of protectionism absolutely so there's
there's one thing at least that all of
us agree on we've got about three four
minutes left if anyone in the audience
has something they want to contribute
are a question that you want to ask I
understand that we don't have the
microphone anymore but I think it's a
small enough room that you can be heard
yes sir back there yes
George it's not that I think that the
problem itself as a psychological issue
I think the problem is very real but
there are a lot of psychological
impediments to dealing with the problem
the effects of anything the consequences
of global climate change are delayed and
we generally tend to not be very good at
dealing with problems that where the
costs are delayed and the where there
are media costs for delayed benefits or
the costs of failing to take action are
delayed the as i said the impact of any
behavior that we do is likely to be
minimal that's the that's the drop in
the bucket effect so there's there's a
lot of psychological reasons why we
can't why this problem is so difficult
to solve I personally think that the
self-serving bias may be the number one
reason but there there are a lot of
other reasons and that was the that was
the point I was making so we need to if
we if we want to try to think of
solutions to the problem we need to take
into account the same psychology which
is contributing to the problem itself
Karen
to climate change in addition to
psychological biases that Georgia's
mentioned there's also there's some real
money at stake for four nations follow
up yesterday's climate change about by
and proclamations by all nations of
their commitment to reduce greenhouse
emissions by 22 so that there won't be a
rise in temperature beyond 2 degrees
Celsius in the next 50 years but then in
detail there was no real commitment from
those states to the kinds of domestic
policies that would be necessary to make
that happen one there's a domestic
audience cost our leaders are facing
elections people at home so that will
affect economic growth if they abide by
these policies furthermore the
developing nations have an incentive to
say that they can't participate in this
without financial and technical
assistance from the developing world so
the EU has committed to between 2 and 15
billion a year to help the developing
states of on issues of climate change so
there are domestic and economic factors
and the way in which i think all states
can kind of gain the system so that they
don't actually have to do very much
they've got domestic factors financial
reasons and so forth and so i think it's
a broad story that includes the
psychological but the others as well if
I know we're running out of time but I
didn't want to say something in response
to Steve Brockman if that's a
possibility
okay Steve we talked about that we can't
create reality but I do believe in a way
the the Jesus domestic expanse is
creating a reality that doesn't truly
exist if you look at all the
communications of these and other
emerging groups like brick they say that
we're in a multipolar world and I think
they're complaining multi polarity and
multilateralism the fact that you have a
lot of actors in an international
institution doesn't mean that you have
various polls of power the United States
still has contributes the line chair of
military spending in the world it is the
single largest nation in terms of GDP
after the EU and China is third but it's
very far behind and so it's not that
there isn't there isn't a reality out
there that still is around a very
powerful united states that much of
these of the international institutions
are trying to deny the rhetoric there
that they're using and so I just wanted
to to make that that point yeah thank
you Karen we really are are out of time
now and as Karen said words are cheap
and we're going to be hearing a lot of
words in the next few days from our
leaders either individually or
collectively action can be harder and
certainly more expensive I hope that our
words here have been of some value to
you and that will have to be I'm afraid
the last word so thank you very much
you